I have genuinely good news for you from the
a world of vaccines in Washington state.
This is a loss for the Anti Vaccine Movement,
which is a win for society.
Uh, and children who can't be vaccinated,
parents will no longer be allowed to get their
kids vaccine exemptions in Washington state
for so called personal or philosophical reasons.
This is for the MMR vaccine if their kids
are going to go to daycare or to school.
Now this is good, but it's also a relatively
small win and I'll explain that in a second.
Um, as you may know, Washington has some anti
vaccs elements and that has led to a spike
in measles cases.
And the governor, Jay Inslee, who is also
running for president says no more personal
or philosophical exemptions.
Now that's good.
The problem is most of the exemptions that
people are getting in Washington are religious,
religious exemptions.
Those are still available.
Of course medical exemptions are in place
as well.
And those are the the only ones that we actually
need a, there may be medical reasons why someone
should not be vaccinated, but as, as long
as we don't do away with the religious exemptions,
um, this is going to remain a major problem
and, uh, it's great that right now, uh, you
will no longer be able to say I'm personally
opposed to vaccines.
I have philosophical objections to vaccination,
but the overwhelming majority of the non medical
exemptions in Washington are religious.
So when you get rid of personal and philosophical,
it's very easy to say, well, what I mean is
it's my religion who can tell you that it's
not right.
Uh, and more importantly, something like 95
or 96, maybe even 98% of the non medical exemptions
are religious to begin with.
So we've got to deal with this.
We should praise the fact that Washington
state is doing the right thing here, but you're
not actually going to deal with this for as
long as someone can say, my religion tells
me that, uh, uh, I should not, uh, get, get
my kid vaccinated.
And of course, philosophical exemptions are
pretty ridiculous.
If you're an anti tax activists and you say,
I'm philosophically against taxation, uh,
it's called the sovereign citizen movement.
It doesn't work.
The government says that that's not a good
explanation.
If you say you're philosophically exempt from
stop signs, stop signs are necessary and good
for society, I don't think you're allowed
to get away with that.
This needs to be considered the same way.
It's the right decision that Washington is
making, but we've got to get rid of those
religious exemptions.
Germs don't care about your philosophy.
They also don't care about your religion.
They'll infect you or your kid or the other
person's kid who's immunocompromised, whether
or not you are religious or whether you have
a philosophical disagreement with vaccination.
And I get really bummed out when I do a story
like this because every time I get emails
from people who say they love the show, but
I'm totally wrong on vaccines and I should
look at Andrew Wakefields work, who of course,
uh, lost his medical license for his deception
on this issue or the medical authorities say
vaccines aren't safe or autism, all of this
stuff.
Um, it, it, it's truly and deeply depressing
to me that even people in our audience who
are mostly informed about what's going on
have fallen hook, line and sinker for the
Anti Vaccine Movement.
Depressing, but a small win, if nothing else
in Washington state